and then there's this other thing that's
just me um I just really love working on
projects that are not home there's
something very um I feel like I didn't
want worked on in Paris it was a great
experience but there's something almost
any baiting you know what you know we're
like you talk about something that you
know so much that you feel afraid every
time you know you point your camera or
the keys to shoot in specific Street
Street edit history people have a
history Who am I petition this one of my
stang ba la la la and I feel like
whenever I shoot excited in italy for
three years and so I had experiences
making short films in Italy and in New
York and there's something more like I
don't care I just go and like I'm not
afraid of being cliche I'm not afraid of
shortcuts I'm gonna fight and at the end
of the day about you what immediate
matters is just kind of like it's easier
to be yourself when you're not afraid of
what other people think of yourself you
know I need and so I love the fact that
I'm really far even geographically for
us knowing the place and just knowing
these people and so I'm it gets me
really excited because I can just offer
my observation and vision of it i cant
pretend to have any sort of knowledge
about it and i tend to really enjoy
revisions you know films there have like
people looking at things in an original
way rather than people explaining or
sharing their knowledge about something
so i don't know for some reason it works
well and so like I got really excited
about making a movie in Palo Alto